Jason Reitman is doing the new
Ghostbusters movie dude yes which is
hilarious of course and and brilliant
and now I can talk about it he you know
for a while
JK Simmons talks Ghostbusters J jonah
Jameson and Commissioner Gordon but
first he's taking on a darker role in
I'm not here directed by Michelle
Schumacher Steve when I play him in I'm
not here is old and and kind of full of
regret and looking back on his life and
wishing that he had done some things
differently we also see two different
periods in the same character's life
one is a sebastian stan playing him as a
twenty-something and then Ian Armitage
who has completely blown up since we
shot the movie plays the same character
as a six-year-old yeah young Sheldon
Mary Shelton this was a year before
young Sheldon is just that's taking this
film a long time to finally come out
what do you like about being directed by
you know your partner in life because
not everybody feels that way
ya know I'm sure it can be prickly in
some cases but we've done you know since
she we met as as peers doing theater in
New York and we're in a Broadway revival
of Peter Pan and then you know years
later she's you know transition
transition and she's stepped behind the
camera made several short films and and
the the two aspects of her as a director
that I really appreciate are just the
kind of vibe that she puts down I find
it all the directors that I've really
enjoyed working with multiple times Sam
Raimi the Coen brothers you know Damien
Jason really create just a good happy
vibe you know and that's that's partly
you know competence and being prepared
and partly just you know being a good
nice person you know that
that creates an environment where you
don't mind spending 12 hours together
you know
working on a out of film and then and
then really with this film in particular
I mean I'm it's very vulnerable sort of
for me as an actor it's very emotionally
raw and physically you know exposed and
it was a blessing to be doing it with
the person that I trust more than
anybody on the planet so it was it was
really an ideal partnering I want to
talk about another one of your frequent
collaborators that you just mentioned
Jason Raymond is doing the new
Ghostbusters movie dude yes which is
hilarious of course and and brilliant
and now I can talk about it he you've
known for a while
yeah I mean I can't wait yeah I can't
wait to see you know what what he's
gonna do with it can you tell us the
least surprising news of all time I can
tell you absolutely nothing ok fair
enough but I'm gonna assume I'm gonna
assume here I know everything you know
I'm not telling you yeah want to talk
about another thing Commissioner Jim
Gordon here love that character want to
see him again but it seems like there's
a little bit of a shift in the Batman
direction yeah again I wish I had
something to offer it well although if I
actually did know more than I do I don't
know where I know that I signed up to do
three movies potentially and and and I
hope there are gonna be two more and you
know it has been you know in and around
and through and you know with a Batman
or Justice League or another Suicide
Squad or where Commissioner Gordon might
end up appearing again I'm you know I'm
open to it
I'm not you know I'm not sitting at home
waiting for the phone to ring
mmm-hmm in the mean time but but yeah I
mean I I hope there's more of that in
the future but if it does you ready to
go if the bat phone rings yeah what
about the Jay jonah Jameson call
tomorrow morning spider-man page one
with a decent picture this time I'm not
closing any doors I mean that was that
was some of the most fun I've ever had
making those first you know the trilogy
with Sam Raimi and Tobey and everybody
in the yeah yeah I'm
I'm hoping I mean my pitch which you're
taking pitches right is that Phil Lord
and Chris Miller have you seen
spider-verse
yes of course it's brilliant it is but
they were talking about possibly adding
like live-action elements and I'm like
why not just dip into that world I mean
if there's a if there's a live-action
character that's gonna fit into a
cartoon that that might be the guy it's
Jay jonah Jameson where can people see
I'm not here you can see I'm not here in
like 25 cities on March 8th in a actual
movie theater including here in Los
Angeles it's at the Laemmle in Santa
Monica but as a lot of films are doing
now which is brilliant we're also out on
video on demand of the same day yeah
March 8th anybody that's not in one of
the cities where the film is playing can
watch it in the comfort of their own
home
[Music]